hey everybody we are back again
second stream today there was a
last-minute scheduling of a coronavirus
Trump White House press conference and
this one is an important one because
Donald Trump has made it very clear he
wants to to use Anthony foutch ease
phrase pouchy missing let it rip Donald
Trump signaling today that he by April
12th wants the economy back open because
something along the lines of the economy
was not meant to be closed it was meant
to be open or something like that so
we're gonna look at some of these clips
I want to welcome everybody watching on
YouTube twitch Twitter and Facebook we
are live on all four platforms with the
upcoming press conference of course of
course of course we will be taking your
questions and comments most easily via
twitch Prime or subscription message
which will show up up at the top in that
vertical blue box and via YouTube super
chat which will show up in the empty
gray bar in the bottom left so here's
the deal 30 out of 50 states have not
done anything yet nothing there's
nothing no orders going on at the state
level maybe some cities did something
but 30 or 50 states have done nothing in
Massachusetts we've just started a stay
at home order and Trump already wants to
end it let's take a look I have some
clips here that we can look at while we
wait so here is Donald Trump's first
mention of this April 12th idea this was
earlier today have to do that I'd love
to have it opened by Easter okay I will
tell you that right now I would love to
have that it's such an important day for
other reasons but I'll make it an
important day for this too I would love
to have the country opened up and just
raring to go by Easter so now Trump was
then of course after doing a Fox News
townhall he then did a Fox News
interview with Bill hammer that's what I
call him his name's really Bill Hemmer
but I call him bill hammer because he
just hammers people with irrelevant
softball quest
and then Trump was asked how did you
pick Easter and of course Trump is
coming up with this stuff as he goes
like there's no real answer to this
stuff but here's what Trump came up with
as to why Easter and now he's actually
saying he wants the churches full on
Easter can you imagine anything more
than Town Hall today you threw out a
date where you think America can be
working again and that's Easter Sunday
that's 19 days from now how did you come
up well it's 19 days but in another
seven because we've been doing this now
for seven so that's from the time we
heard about 700 time well yes it's
around the time we close it up so you
can add seven tonight
look Easter is a very special day for me
no it's not and I see it's sort of in
that timeline then by the way this is
Corona voice I don't know if you guys
have to have noticed that Trump has now
adopted this he like it's an exaggerated
version of his voice and we're calling
it Corona voice about and I say wouldn't
it be great to have all of the churches
full you know the churches aren't
allowed essentially to have much of a
congregation there right and most of
them read the disease to get churches
full watched on Sunday online and he was
terrific by the way but Ortolan is never
gonna be like being there right so I
think Easter Sunday and you'll have
packed churches all over our country I
think would be a beautiful time and it's
just about the timeline that I think is
right it gives us more chance to work on
what we're doing and so I'm sure that's
gonna be the day but oh boy I would love
to me here's the deal if Donald Trump
were to come and so I think that April
12th is just too it's too soon this is
the reality we're not even we're not
even close to the peak here in the
United States I mean we're not yet we're
building to a bigger and bigger peak
it's completely crazy to talk about
April 12th if you said to me Trump's
mentioning April 12th how do you want
him to do it right what I would say is
have Trump come out and say listen I
want to get the company the [ __ ] the
economy reopened and I want to do it on
April 12th you are going to have to help
me governor's all 50 governors need to
do stay at
orders from today until April 12th many
of you aren't doing it Charlie Baker in
Massachusetts is doing it Gavin used to
be a little right but thirty of you
aren't doing a damn thing if every
governor says stay home order until
April 12th you may may put me in the
position to get at least the economy
partially reopened on April 12 older
folks will still have to stay home we'll
probably still not be able to do schools
or but we can do something on April 12
that may that's the one scenario where
maybe you could look at doing this uh
and it's still remember I'm saying if
you put a gun to my head and say Trump's
gonna do April 12 but tell him how to do
it that's what I would say there is no
way that this will work especially since
you have so many governors that haven't
done anything yet you are going to still
be seeing the exponential climb come
April 12 the way that things are going
so it's it's just you know it's not
gonna work guys it's not gonna work the
way that it's being done and then you
get to well our airlines going to
increase domestic flights our state's
going to have to start blocking their
borders or they're gonna be walls built
around state not literal walls but
metaphorical ones where there will be
checkpoints coming into states where
like Massachusetts will say well we we
can't do it we're doing our thing here
so we're not gonna be able to I don't
know but this is extremely risky and
then meanwhile you have people like
Texas lieutenant governor Dan Patrick
saying he's a grandfather and he's
willing to sacrifice himself and I guess
he's willing to sacrifice other
grandparents to take a listen living in
fear of is what's happening to this
country and you know Tucker no one
reached out to me and said as a senior
citizen are you willing to take a chance
on your survival in exchange for keeping
the America that all America loves for
your children and grandchildren and if
that's the exchange I'm all-in
and that doesn't make me Noble or brave
or anything like that I just think there
are lots of grandparents out there in
this country like me I have six
grandchildren that what we all care
about and what we love more than
anything are those children and I
want to you know live smart and and see
through this but I don't want the whole
country to be sacrificed and I know what
he means by that is the stock market to
be down there it's just coded language
now and I found this video it did I I
don't um
it's not clear whether this is a hold on
a second excuse me there we go I don't
this is the video is called Milton
Friedman puts a young Michael Moore in
his place I don't know if this is
actually Michael Moore the filmmaker or
not so I took down a tweet where I said
it was but basically this is the debate
that they're having take a listen
it has to do with the the Ford Pinto I'm
not sure if you're aware of recent
revelations that have come out about the
production of that car Ford produced it
knowing full well that in any rear-end
collision the gas tank would blow up
because they had failed to install $13
plastic block in front of the gas tank
and Ford estimated in an internal memo
that that would cost about 200 lives a
year and they estimated further that the
cost of each life would be two hundred
thousand dollars they multiplied and
they found that the cost of installing
those blocks in each of the cars would
be more than the cost of saving those
two hundred lives and over the past
seven years the car has been produced
and over a thousand lives have been lost
it seems to me that Ford did what would
be the right thing according to your
policy and yet that seems to me to be
very wrong well let me ask you let's
suppose it would have cost a billion
dollars per person should for to put
them in a nonetheless the print you're
not arguing about principle you're no no
no because nobody can take the principle
nobody can accept so the idea here is
listen are we arguing about principle or
are we arguing about price if it costs
thirteen dollars per car to fix the gas
tank and the deaths every life is worth
two hundred K you know whatever is it
about the value of the thirteen dollars
or is it the principle here and this is
the problem with these sometimes
economists make these delusional
arguments that you have
go to infinity in order to make a case
and the reality is we're not talking
about infinity that's the prop that's
where a lot of this stuff falls apart
Milton Friedman's argument is if you
take this to infinity even if it cost a
billion dollars you would you would say
Ford still has to do it the reality is
it's a 3500 freaking dollar car it was
in the 1970s the Ford Pinto
it would never get to infinity and
that's why you know when you start
hearing people say well if we if we take
down the economy for a hundred thousand
lives or we take down the economy for
ten thousand lives or are we are we only
talking about a thousand lives because
we're okay losing a thousand extra
people to take back the account or
whatever it's always this idea of would
we sacrifice the economy no matter what
and of course the answer is that's not
what we're talking about we're talking
about temporary measures we're talkin
AMA stuff already looked the economy
would eventually recover
yes it will be short-term pain but who
are these other people to say we're
gonna sacrifice grandma or whoever the
case may be it's not their call to make
and unfortunately Donald Trump is taking
it upon himself and apparently he's
decided April 12th is the day and that's
when he wants churches full for Easter
extraordinarily extraordinarily
irresponsible let me say thank you to
Anthony Reedus Anthony Reedus has just
signed up at join pakman.com and his new
member number one today look at that
just a little just a little filling up
the bar there just a little bit I also
want to say thanks to Alex Fraser
Alex Fraser is new member number two
today at join pakman.com Alex and
Anthony thank you guys so much if you're
just joining us on YouTube let me I
don't want to be labor the point but
please make sure to hit that like button
every time someone hits like I don't
know something good happens more people
coming to the stream make sure to LIKE
and subscribe very very important we're
also live on Twitter Facebook and twitch
and if you're watching on Twitch let me
actually thank a few people rip pause
Belltown has subscribed with prime
symbolic gamer
has subscribed with Prime epic hatchet
is now a prime subscriber and Jala hippo
has also subscribed with Prime and says
are you worried about a possible delay
to the election in November a check out
my YouTube clip about that I do have a
YouTube clip out about that right now
okay as people continue to like the
stream on YouTube I'm gonna answer some
of these super chat questions marika
says do people travel during Easter a
lot in the US I don't know I'm Jewish
but I presume that some people do Marika
goes on to say then they'll spread it oh
there's gonna believe me if we let her
rip on April 12th cases are going to
explode Stephen Hart says somebody stop
this lunatic I am begging you all yeah
I'm actually now getting frantic calls
from friends and relatives saying is he
really doing this is Trump really gonna
let her rip on April 12th we have to
stop him and there's every indication
that he is going to that's why today's
press briefing is so important my guess
is Trump you know he floated it on
Sunday night with we want to make sure
the cure is not worse than the disease
yesterday he tweeted about it again he
said I'm thinking of weeks not months
today he floats April April 12th as a
partial reopen then he says I want the
churches full on April 12th it's every
every six hours it's building and we'll
see what they say today let's see here
Bailey says how do super chats work I
don't remember putting credit card
information on youtube or Google I don't
know but you just sent me five bucks so
you must have done something
love inspired says I'm willing to bet my
life that he doesn't even know the
significance of Easter probably not
michael says Disney is still firm on
reopening on April 1st that that's
incredible Alex Jones says who is the
worst conservative commentator don't
know don't watch any of them Samantha
Sabatino says to deepak streams in one
day we are so lucky thank you glad to be
here Grace Lee says Co vid is the black
light on the bedsheets of capitalism
beautiful imagery I love that Ingo yalla
has grabbed a YouTube membership Sam
Dean says g'day mate New South Wales
just reported their first case of Co vyd
in a person under the age of 10
Queensland has closed its border to New
South Wales things are happening
yeah let's quickly look at the numbers
let's see what we've got today we now
are officially at 400 so take a look by
the way at how long it took let me see
if we can look at this so it took us how
long did it take to get to a hundred
thousand it took you know a while it
took months to get to a hundred thousand
then it took from March sixth through
March seventeenth that took eleven days
to get to two hundred thousand then from
two to three it took only about nine and
a half days from three to four it took
three days so as you guys can see it's
it's getting very very very ugly let's
look at the United States numbers real
quick where is that oh I'm in the wrong
on the wrong page apologies let's look
at the United States number of course
the numbers don't tell us very much
because we are under testing we know we
have had 685 deaths
many many new cases we had almost 400
new cases today here in Massachusetts
5,000 new cases in New York and as we
look at the numbers we had 10,000 new
cases yesterday and today so far it's
looking like five seven well okay we'll
see by the end of the day what what the
number is today but but things are not
looking good in terms of deaths today
where are the new oh I should just go
back for the new deaths right new deaths
in the u.s. 132 we had 140 yesterday my
guess is by the end of the day
tragically we will be over 140 so that's
where things are that's where things are
here at this point in time let me say
thank you to Bernie Cohn Murray big bad
Greg Titanic his gardens and narbon our
ball skies all of whom
some bits and subscribed on Twitch as
well as big Luna big Luna has just
grabbed or gifted a subscription let me
say thank you to Anthony Hutchins
Anthony is new member number three today
at join pakman.com Robert Sands lit is
new member number four Matt cleric is
new member number five thank you very
much appreciate appreciate the support
very very strongly as we are now waiting
here for the start of today's press
conference other super chats coming in
essential says guess we'll know how
screwed we are on April 24th that'll be
a big day
Walker Anderson says is the fact that
Republicans plan is less than ideal
justification for proposals from the
green new deal or diversity quotas in a
vital aid package I don't want to do the
both sides thing but there are both
Republicans and Democrats who are doing
really really ugly stuff when it comes
to just getting something passed and
getting money to people we have live
video now and we are standing by we will
presumably see the room start to fill up
as we get closer to the start of today's
press conference
Rhian Wilson says he has to say what I
type I'm controlling David Pakman Smith
right now who is David P ACK ma n I
don't know who that is it's certainly
not me okay Michael marks has grabbed a
youtube membership Bailey says I checked
my bank account I don't see any charges
listen Bailey I don't know how you're
sending super chats if you are not
actually paying but YouTube is paying me
that's what matters if you somehow have
found free money congratulations comrade
Matthias oh by the way most likely if
you have an Android phone you have gute
the Google Play Store at some point you
probably entered your credit card
information and I'm guessing that's how
the super chats are being charged if I
had to guess although I don't know about
it
comrade Matthias says pasta or pizza
both of course both Anthony Rita says
David longtime listener voting Pakman
for 2020 by the way my last name is
pronounced
read us read us okay read Anthony Redis
I apologize
Samantha Marx has grabbed a soy boy
level YouTube membership Charlie says
I've been managing my I had been
managing my stress levels pretty well
until about 12 hours ago now they're
spiking yeah along with the stock market
apparently which is of course all Donald
Trump seems to care about hound dog says
we need a campaign for everyone to flood
governor's offices with phone calls
demanding then they take action into
their own hands and ignore the federal
government yeah we need I think I
tweeted earlier let me see if I can find
it
we already looked at this video this is
all on my Twitter where you you could be
following me right now look at this this
is recursive this is me watching the
Twitter feed of my own stream can you
imagine that so this is the latest
states that have told people to stay
home versus states that have not purple
are statewide orders we have one here in
Massachusetts light purple is an order
in part of the state it's pretty wide
open and of course Donald Trump will say
a lot of these states have very few
cases remember what matters is per
capita and what matters is the
exponential growth of the cases so it's
we're not going to solve it with so few
states actually doing anything it's it's
we're just not gonna do it
it's gonna be months and months Shaun
Flanagan says the UK death toll has
risen to 420 to 87 new deaths there it's
getting bad everywhere my friends Chris
TJ says my mother-in-law thinks God put
Trump in power for some religious
reasons how do we awake these deluded
people breaks my heart she's a good lady
I wish I knew I wish I knew Christie but
my my girlfriend has some family members
who have a similar view to what you're
mentioning there and they are posting
how amazing Trump's press briefings have
been how give how blessed we are yeah
there's there's no there's no talking
talking sense it's just it's sad it's
sad but that's where we are right now
let me say thank you to grungey Dan for
cheering on twitch as well as the
new twitch Prime subscription from MFG
1173 very much appreciate that alex
jones says is socialized medicine to
blame for italy's problems well there
are countries with socialized medicine
doing well and countries with socialized
medicine not doing so well
so i don't believe that that is the the
x-factor Sam Kenyon says governor
Reynolds in my state Iowa said in a
press conference today that
shelter-in-place will do nothing to
combat corona virus since its worldwide
so frustrating well what that means is
everybody should shelter in place not
that nobody should shelter in place
that's a very defeatist attitude thanks
to Lee Mead for grabbing a youtube
subscription Kelly says Texas is in the
worst state of mind they just banned
abortion rights love you David I haven't
I saw Ohio trying to restrict abortions
didn't see Texas doing it under the
auspices of kovat that is so they're
generally speaking they're always trying
to ban abortion Walker Anderson says
fair enough I am on the right and it is
us too right
Santa Clause says hey are you hiring
looks like I'm not going to have the
turnout this year for Christmas and I
still got bills to pay we are not
currently hiring but fortunately we are
also not laying people off or reducing
ours which which I'm glad to say and is
very much supported by people who sign
up on our website so YouTube YouTube
revenue is down about 20-ish percent and
a lot of people tightening the belt when
it comes to memberships understandably
so yeah I really appreciate everybody
who's been signing up on my website
during the streams Gomer Roth says it's
true that a hundred people a day die to
car accidents couldn't we be justified
to shut down freeways until we have
self-driving cars am i off base here's
why so here's the thing car accidents
are not increasing exponentially the
fact that there is a cost to people
traveling around in vehicles is a
reality it's been around for a long time
and it is not an
crisis whose exponential increase is
following you know a curve like this
right if you had automobile driving look
like this you would have a different
situation
you
what on earth just happened that was so
weird how long was i off I didn't even
know can anybody tell me how long I was
gone that was that was a long one I
don't know how that happened I clearly
hit the wrong thing can anybody tell me
how long I was gone that was bad
20 seconds 20 minutes now I know that's
not true
15 to 20 seconds okay I was thanking a
few people sorry about that
that one got ugly that was a bit that
was a doozy as we would say I'm back
though I'm back people are asking if I'm
giving away free stuff yes so we have a
protocol okay every five new members on
my website every five new members one
person right one person gets a free item
and instead of doing it right at 5 and
10 and 15 because then people just wait
and then they try to be number 5 or
number 10 every 5 we pick someone right
so for example either Anthony Hutchins
Robert sands Lit Matt cleric Anthony
Redis or Alex Fraser one of the five of
you will get a free item from the david
pakman show online store we've been
emailing people after the stream we've
got a couple more people signing up
Michael Lucas is new member number six
and then Ernest
diem ah so is new member number seven so
if we get members eight nine and ten
one of those five will get a free item
from the David Pakman show online store
um somebody suggested that I make a data
male emote on twitch I think we have all
our emotes are full I think we only get
five or something like that
but I'm definitely open to that if
someone if someone makes it I'm willing
to add it if we I just I thought we were
at our limit I don't know okay other
people signing up or sending messages
Rhian Wilson says I love how South Korea
has handled the pandemic yes and the
numbers are increasingly ups good in
South Korea
NK star says Ferengi Republic
prophets of above all unknown prodigy
says Trump thinks he's doing great with
the Dow up mm yes he does
Nolan Wall says I am immunodeficient due
to cancer treatment I'm feeling
abandoned by Trump and his cronies
cancer patients and survivors are just
forgotten you know they seem willing to
sacrifice a lot of people older folks
immunocompromised folks it's truly
horrible
it's truly horrible and Trump seems
determined to as he likes to say let it
as Anthony foul she says let it rip on
April 12th Owl
acquatic says when is he going to start
throwing paper towels yeah remember when
Donald Trump in fact we can find the
video just to show you well we have time
here
Trump Puerto Rico paper towels Trump
thought that a great thing to do after
the Puerto Rican hurricane was to go and
to start shooting paper towel rolls like
like basketballs and I'm trying to see
okay here I think we've got a video here
of it
just moments away this is this is how
Donald Trump decided to yeah check it
out what an empathetic guy this is the
guy I want showing up to comfort me in a
time of tragedy boom there you go yep
anyway yeah that's the slo-mo I don't
know that we necessarily need that so
there it is so anyway I don't think I
don't think this guy is playing with a
full deck when it comes to empathy if
you're just joining us on YouTube
remember to hit that like button and
also hit the subscribe button both are
useful probably subscribe more than like
subscribe more than but both are very
very useful and always appreciated and
the streams increasingly popular with
the people I think in part because of
the heavy heavy liking and subscribing
thought loop says what his thought loops
a Maine Governor announced today all
non-essential all public business and
workspaces that cannot social distance
closed the schools may still be open
it's something Damian Garvey says why
don't you watch conservative or liberal
commentators is it just not a good use
of your time yeah I do do enough reading
to prepare for this show that when I'm
not doing that
I'm reading you know science nonfiction
narrative nonfiction you know playing
chess playing drums exercising all that
all that sort of stuff so I just don't I
just don't have time to fit in watching
other people who do what I do
Keaton clapper says David what's your
favorite drum songs to play I don't know
uh Led Zeppelin good times bad times is
a great song here's dr. Burks foutch she
returns the return of dr. Anthony foul
she looking spry at seventy-nine spry at
79
oh dear God Larry Kudlow is here is he
drunk and what is he going to say if
Kudlow is here it's almost a guarantee
that they are going to start talking
about letting it rip and oh boy I'm I'm
I'm scared I'm very very scared I'm not
gonna lie let me say thanks to Josh my
hill Josh my hill is new member number
eight today at join pakman.com richard
Solvang is new member number nine here
is trump so i'll keep thanking folks in
a little bit do we have audio I'm not
hearing a damn thing
nothing's muted either how weird all
right we'll be over here I guess thank
you very much a very busy day I want to
thank the American people for the
incredible sacrifices that they're
making on behalf of our nation and I
want to encourage everyone to keep
following our guidelines on social
distancing avoiding large gatherings and
hand-washing and all of the other things
that everybody knows they're supposed to
be doing ultimately the goal is to ease
the guidelines and open things up to
very large sections of our country as we
near the end of our historic battle with
the invisible enemy to go on for a while
but we win win I said earlier today that
I hope we can do this by Easter I think
that would be a great thing for our
country and we're all working very hard
to make that a reality we'll be meeting
with a lot of people to see if it can be
done
Easter is a very special day for many
reasons for me or blowing of that a lot
of our friends that's a very special day
and what a great timeline this would be
Easter is our timeline what a great
timeline that would be my first priority
is always now she's not a flag the
American people I don't want everyone to
understand that we are continuing to
evaluate the data we're working with the
task force and making decisions based on
what is best for the interest of our
fantastic country in order to defeat the
virus we must continue to be very strong
your resilience and spirit has been
inspiring to everyone right now this
virus is attacking 149 countries but
everybody looks to us and they're
watching us really people looking at
South very hard to be your president I
can tell you that there's tremendous
hope as we look forward and we begin to
see the light at the end of the tunnel
stay focused and stay strong and my
administration and myself will deliver
for you as we have in the past let me
provide you an update on critical
preparations and supplies in a war on
the virus through FEMA the federal
government is distributing more than 8
million n95 respirators 14 million
surgical masks and many many millions
more under order and they'll be arriving
soon 2.4 million face shields 1.9
million surgical gowns 13.5 million
gloves and more than four thousand
ventilators to the areas of greatest
need have already been sent and we have
four thousand being delivered to New
York the federal government Elon Musk
got 1200 ventilators in 36 hours they're
still talking about this first 4,000 in
weeks eyes the core element of this
strategy is my executive order
authorizing the use of the defense
production Act which as as you know
already been activated actually a long
time ago quite a long time ago private
companies are heating are called to
produce medical equipment and supplies
because they know that we will not
hesitate to invoke the DPA in order to
get them to do what they have to do it's
called leverage you don't have to you
use it from the standpoint of actually
it's been activated but you don't have
to use it but the threat of it being
there's great leverage and companies are
doing as we asked and companies are
actually even better than that they're
coming
and they're calling us and it's been
really something to see this morning
Ford 3m General Electric Healthcare are
making tremendous numbers they've
already started respirators ventilators
and face shields they're working
together we didn't have to exercise or
utilize the DPA in any way the fact that
we have it helps but we didn't have to
and for the most part we won't have to
we're receiving full cooperation from
companies with the understanding that
the federal government stands ready to
compel cooperation if need be we haven't
found that to be the case it's been
really amazing to see these big strong
powerful in some cases very small
companies family-owned companies step up
and make a lot of great product for what
we're going through and what we will
continue to be going through for a while
exciting products for our one of our
engineers in the National Guard are
building for hospital facilities in New
York City at the Javits Center which
will be operational very soon they've
already started in addition they're
building four separate medical
facilities in different parts of the
state we're dealing with Governor Cuomo
on that so you can have four hospitals
and four medical facilities at the
highest level to really incredible
facilities temporary but incredible
we're also deploying the US Navy
hospital ship and that will be arriving
in New York Harbor in the
not-too-distant future it's finishing
its maintenance they're doing a very big
maintenance and what we did is we
condensed it very seriously and as you
know the other hospital ship and these
are incredible ships it's already on its
way to Los Angeles so we're in frequent
contact with state and local officials
and getting a lot of work done we're
likewise building hospitals in Los
Angeles we're working also the state of
Washington
we're working with the governor of the
state of New Jersey building a medical
facility a hospital facility and doing a
lot of work I want to thank the people
from FEMA the great people from FEMA and
also the Army Corps of Engineers
secretary minuchin and the members of my
administration continue to work closely
with Congress I'm pleased to report that
we are working to pass the biggest and
boldest financial relief package in
American history senators will soon
hopefully vote on a two trillion dollar
bill that will deliver direct cash
payments to struggling Americans no
fault of their own this came out of Walt
nowhere nobody can imagine this even
happened
but it's not their fault we want to
protect and we will all of the things
that a person needs protected and a
family needs protected we're working on
job retention loans for small businesses
and extended unemployment insurance for
laid off workers the legislation will
also include billions of dollars for
additional resources for our and really
heroic these are incredible doctors
nurses brave and hospitals as well as
support for hard-hit industries such as
the airline industry and the cruise ship
industry which employ tremendous amounts
of people and obviously sir very
important functions beyond that with
very tough protections for the American
taxpayer the loans will be very secure
and they will be very profitable and so
they're gonna be profitable rail bridge
they call them bridge loans in many
cases they'll be bridging these
companies back into very good health
some of them are very important
companies said four weeks ago didn't
have a problem I'm also confident that
the Democrats will do the right thing I
feel very confident they're working very
hard together right now Republicans and
Democrats and they're getting very close
to a very fair deal and I've been
getting worried this entire kovat thing
wasn't gonna be profitable for anybody
but hey clearly it will be the dow
surged over 2,100 points and see
all time record history of the exchange
this is very encouraging and I think
part of the reason is they are looking
at what is close to being passed and I
think a very big part of it is they see
that we want to get our country open as
soon as possible they see we're working
very hard on that that's a very big
factor I think in today's historic game
the legislation developed in the Senate
is the first step to restoring
confidence and stability to America's
economy as we look ahead to the time
when we can carefully and responsibly
reopen our country for business and we
hope that's going to be very soon now
one wish your Americans that we have a
team of public health experts we've
gotten to know them as well as I know
them they're great people incredible
talented they love our country also
economists and other professionals
working to develop a sophisticated plan
to reopen the economy as soon as the
time is right one based on the best
science the best modeling and the best
we need to hear about treatments and
protocol rather than just stocks and
companies and profitable loans and
especially when it comes to our public
health experts and officials have been
helping other countries dealing with
other countries constant touch with
other countries helping them out because
many of them have never seen anything
like what's happening but our decision
will be based on hard facts and data as
to the opening I'm also hopeful to have
Americans working again by that Easter
that beautiful Easter day perfect debt
but rest assured every decision we make
is grounded solely in the health safety
and well-being of our citizens this is a
medical crisis this isn't a financial
crisis but it's a thing that nobody has
seen for many many decades nothing like
this marshalling our economic strength
is a key feature of defeating the virus
producing the material supplies and
equipment that we need and they're doing
a really fantastic job we're helping the
governors we had a conference call the
other day with the governors and
we allowed the press to join us on the
call and the spirit between us and the
governor's has been really great we
should never be reliant on a foreign
country
for the means of our own survival I
think we've learned a lot we've learned
a lot this crisis has underscored just
how critical it is to have strong
borders can someone turn down that
camera shutter that's super annoying
sure for three years we've embarked on a
great national project to secure
immigration system and bring back our
manufactured you really need a hundred
pictures of this records numbers of
record numbers of jobs and this really
shows this experience shows how
important borders are without borders
you don't have a nation our goal for the
future must be to have American medicine
for American patients American supplies
for American hospitals and American
equipment for our great American heroes
now both parties must unite to ensure
the United States is truly an
independent nation in every sense of the
word energy independence we've
established that and something
incredible that we've established where
energy independent manufacturing
independence economic independence and
territorial independence enforced by
strong sovereign borders America will
never be a supplicant nation we will be
a proud prosperous independent and
self-reliant nation we will embrace
commerce with all but we will be
dependent on none above all we know that
the best thing for our economy and the
world right now is a very very powerful
victory over the virus every day the
American people are showing the unity
and resolve that is always defined the
character of our nation in New York
citizens are using 3d printers to make
hundreds of face shields they're making
them by the hundred
you know those things where it's like
that's cool and all but maybe if you had
acted more quickly they wouldn't need to
be 3d printing face masks these selfless
actions of our amazing citizens we're
seeing enduring strength of our
magnificent nation a spirit that can
never be broken and a victorious future
that can never be denied it never will
be denied now what I'd like to do is
perhaps ask a person who has really
established herself as maybe the world's
great expert on what she does whatever
it is she does Deborah to come forward
and say a few words and then I'll ask
Tony to come up and speak and then our
Vice President and they will take a few
questions and we'll do it quickly and
we'll probably see you again tomorrow
so Deborah please please Deborah I think
those of you who heard the townhall we
are continuing to accelerate testing at
a record rate we now have 370 thousand
tests that have been done majority of
those over 220,000 in the last eight
days which of those of you who have been
tracking the South Korea numbers put us
equivalent to what they did in eight
weeks that we did in eight days this was
made possible because of the HHS team
working together bringing together the
strength of the FDA with the CDC and the
under the leadership of secretary azar
we're very proud of those numbers but we
know that we have to do more and we
continue to accelerate in testing to
ensure that the those who need the tests
are tested first and have access as we
talked about yesterday we're working on
the ability for people to take their own
sample that does not mean home testing
that means taking your own sample in the
front of your nose with available swabs
into normal saline that can be
transplanted its transported to the
laboratories that will allow and free up
all of the drive-throughs to see very
sparing on PPE because you'll be able to
do that with gloves rather than the full
PPE outfits this voucher will be hiding
behind the flag soon to be dedicated to
our hospitals I think those of you are
tracking this epidemic closely like I am
you will begin to see that there is
encouraging results coming out of Italy
we are impressed by this the decreases
that are seen in mortality the number of
people succumbing to this illness and
the number of new cases our new cases
will continue to surge because we're
still working on our backlog although we
will be in touch with the laboratories
after this president well there are also
30 states aren't doing a damn thing how
many were run in the last 24 hours until
we can get into a 24 hour cycle we're
gonna have disproportional number of new
cases compared to the actual new cases
and we will let you know when we've
reached that equilibrium finally and I
know dr. Falchi will talk about this
further we remain deeply concerned about
New York City and the min New York metro
area about 56% of all the cases in the
United States are coming out of that
metro area and 60% of all the new cases
are coming out of the Metro New York
area and 31% of the peoples are coming
to this disease it means because they
still are at the 31 percent mortality
compared to the other regions of the
country that we can have a huge impact
if we unite together this means as in
all places they have to be following the
presidential guidelines that were put
out eight or nine days ago and this will
be critical but to everyone who has left
New York over the last few days because
of the rate of the number of cases you
may have been exposed before you left
New York and I think like governor de
Santos has put out today everybody who
was in Santa Fe self quarantine for the
next 14 days to ensure that the virus
doesn't spread to others no matter where
they have gone whether it's Florida
North Carolina or out too far far
reaches of Long Island we are starting
to see new cases across new across Long
Island that suggests people have left
city so this will be very critical that
those individuals do self quarantine in
their homes over these next 14 days to
make sure they don't pass the virus to
others based on the time that they left
New York so if they've already are four
days out then it's just ten more days so
I thank you if you helped get that
message out to others
dr. pouchy finally thank you very much
mr. president Deb I want to just talk
very briefly about two or three things
first the issue of testing and how that
has really changed the complexion of the
approach that will gonna be able to take
we right know testing was an issue we
had many questions of testing in this
room for a number of times now that we
literally have hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of testing out there there are
a few things that we can do with that
one of the things is that when we make
policy about what we're gonna be doing
with the rest of the country
particularly those areas that are not
hotspots we need to know what the
penetrance of infection is there so we
need to put a light on those dark spots
that we don't know we have to act policy
wise on data and we're gonna be getting
more data a lot more data the other
thing is that the areas of the country
that are not hotspots that are not going
through the terrible ordeal that New
York and California and Washington state
are going through they still have a
window of a significant degree of being
able to contain in other words when you
test you find somebody you isolate them
you get them out of circulation and you
do the contact tracing when you have a
big outbreak it's tough to do anything
but mitigation we have an opportunity
now that we have the availability of
testing to do that so you're gonna be
hearing more about how we can inform
where we're going which is why Trump
should say 50 states should do stay at
home and start testing asymptomatic
people DeBerg said about New York if
it's a very serious situation they've
suffered terribly through no fault of
their own but what we're seeing now is
that understandably people want to get
out of New York they're going to Florida
they're going to Long Island to go into
different places the idea if you look at
the statistics it's disturbing
about one per thousand
these individuals are infected that's
about eight to ten times more than in
other areas which means when they go to
another place for their own safety
they've got to be careful monitor
themselves if they get sick bring it to
the attention of a physician get tested
also the idea about self isolating for
two weeks will be very important because
we don't want that to be another seeding
point to the rest of the country
wherever they go and then thirdly just
one one just comment about about drugs
and the testing of drugs you know the
you heard yesterday about drugs being
out there
that physicians on an off-label way can
prescribe it to give people hope of
something that hasn't been definitively
proven to work but that might have some
hope I don't want anybody to forget
that's simultaneously without doing that
we're also doing randomized clinical
trials on a number of candidates
you've heard about candidates but there
are others in the pipeline where we'll
be able to design the study and over a
period of time particularly since we
have so many infections we'll be able to
determine definitively are these safe
and are they effective we're talking
about room Dissidia other drugs immune
sera convalescent sera monoclonal
antibodies all of these are in the
pipeline now queuing up to be able to go
into clinical trial so I'll stop there
and oh god is Kudlow drunk we're gaining
great progress on this phase three
legislation negotiations continue we've
had continued reports I've been up there
with Secretary of monition secretary
monition continues today with chief of
staff mark meadows checking in with the
president they were getting closer and
closer they expect to vote as soon as
possible I just want to walk through a
couple of key points that this
legislation is urgently needed to
bolster the economy provide cash
injections and liquidity and stabilize
financial markets to get us through a
difficult period a difficult and
challenging period in the
me facing us right now but also to
position us for what I think can be an
economic rebound later this year we
started the year very strong and then we
got hit by the coronavirus in ways that
probably nobody imagined possible we're
dealing with that as best we can
this package will be the single largest
Main Street assistance program in the
history of the United States the single
largest funny to hear them now bragging
about how much they're going to spend
before saying it's socialism and we
can't afford it the sick leave for
individuals hourly workers families and
so forth phase three a significant
package for small businesses loan
guarantees will be included we're gonna
take out expenses and lost revenues as a
president said eligibility requires
worker retention we will maintain the
people eligible will maintain their
payrolls during this crisis period and
on top of that we will have direct
deposit checks of roughly $3,000 for a
family of four and that will bridge to
seven hands for post up unemployment
insurance benefits that will essentially
take those up to full wages this is one
two three four you know a strong
workforce requires strong business you
can't have a job without a business to
work for and hope here is that the
companies that are operating very well
at the beginning of the year when the
economy was in good shape we will help
them and their employees get through
this tough period so they will come out
the other side let's say this later this
spring or summer and will continue their
operations that's the key point
now don't forget there's income tax
deferrals for individuals and
corporations without interest in
penalties their student loan interest
and principal deferrals without any
penalties and finally I want to mention
the Treasury's exchange stabilization
refund that will be replenished it's
important because that fund opens the
door for
reserve fire power to deal a broad-based
way throughout the economy for
distressed industries for small
businesses for financial turbulence
you've already seen the Fed take action
they intend to take more action and in
order to get this we have to replenish
the Treasury's emergency fund it's very
very important not everybody understands
that that fund by the way will be
overseen by an oversight board and an
inspector general it will be completely
transparent so the total package here
comes to roughly six trillion dollars
two trillion direct assistance roughly
four trillion in federal reserve lending
power again there will be the largest
Main Street financial package in the
history of the United States liquidity
and cash for families small businesses
individuals unemployed to keep this
thing going
we're headed for a rough period but it's
only gonna be weeks we think weeks
months not gonna be years that's for
sure and hopefully pave the way for
continued economic recovery after this
crisis didn't sound drunk for that voice
for so many years like 30 years or more
maybe and it's a great voice and it's a
great man so Larry Kudlow thank you very
much I want to say that that package and
we went over parts of it but pretty big
parts it really sets us up to I think
even supersede where we were a month ago
I think we can get up there quickly and
I think it allows us to supersede super
to help these great companies that need
help like Boeing which is you know had a
problem and then on top of that problem
it had the virus come in but we'll be
helping Boeing we'll be helping the
airlines now she totally blossoms we'll
be doing a lot of things and the money
will all come back to us and it'll come
back to us in a very strong form and
before we take some questions I'd like
to ask our great vice president to say a
few words if you would live mr.
president the coronavirus task force met
this morning Thank You mr. president the
White House coronavirus task force met
again today
and on behalf of the President of the
United States everyone on our team
I know state leaders let me just say
Thank You America people across this
country businesses large and small are
responding to the threat of the corona
virus in ways that are deeply inspiring
people are acting on the president's
power few days to slow the spread and it
is making a material difference our
experts standing beside us I told us
that if every American regardless of
whether you're in an area that's
impacted by an outbreak of the corona
virus or not if every American would
embrace these guidelines that we could
significantly reduce the number of
Americans that would contract the corona
virus and protect the most vulnerable
and as the president reflected earlier
tens of millions of Americans are doing
just that and we're grateful the focus
of our task force of course is to slow
the spread to promote mitigation
strategies beyond that though the
president has us focused on testing and
on supplies and making sure that those
that are enduring the symptoms of the
corona virus and those who are
ministering to them our extraordinary
health care workers have the support
that they need in the category of
supplies you just heard dr. Burks
indicate that we've made great progress
we have done more tests in the last
eight days then we're done in the
previous eight weeks and it's because of
the public-private partnership that the
president forged with commercial labs
and I would encourage people around the
country to remind your family members
and friends if you don't have symptoms
don't get a test we want to make sure
people who are having symptoms who have
a concern I have the ability to be
tested and to have those tests process
we're continuing to urge all County
hospitals all labs around the country to
report to the CDC all the results of the
tests as it'll give these experts around
us the ability to continue to advise the
President on best practices
as I mentioned we we all continue to
follow this the outbreak around the
country and the test results but as
several have mention were particularly
focused on on New York the reality is
the New York metro area was 60% of the
new cases in the country and
specifically as a lay person I can tell
you that the infection rates are roughly
one in 1,000 in the New York City
metropolitan area where they are 0.2%
per thousand or 0.1% 4000 in place just
like Washington State it is the reason
why today the white house coronavirus
task force is calling on any American
first and foremost if you're in the New
York City metropolitan area or elsewhere
to take the guidelines that we issued
and avoid non-essential travel but for
anyone in the New York metropolitan area
who has traveled our task force is
encouraging you to monitor your
temperature be sensitive to symptoms and
we are asking anyone who has traveled
out of the New York City metropolitan
area to anywhere else in the country to
self isolate for 14 days we have to deal
with the New York City metropolitan area
as a high-risk area and for that reason
we're we're taking these steps and ask
you for the cooperation of the American
people because of the spread in New York
City we will continue to surge resources
the president's describe this FEMA is
coordinating with New York State for the
arrival of the USS comfort in just a
matter of a few short weeks we over the
next 24 hours more than 4,000 additional
ventilators will be delivered to a New
York State as well New York State has
prioritized three alternative medical
facilities and at the president's
direction the Army Corps of engineer is
working on plans to build those
facilities out you've heard the
president speak about the Javits Center
the addition of a thousand
and will continue I want the people of
New York City and the Greater New York
City area to know that we're with you
we're going to continue to provide
resources to support your state and
local officials as they confront the
spread of the corona virus in that great
city on the subject of supplies we had
team meetings today at FEMA which is
working on identifying the critical
personal protective equipment and
ventilators at this point FEMA informs
us today that they are distributing 7.6
million n95 respirator masks more than
14 million surgical masks and FEMA has
already shipped 73 pallets of personal
protective equipment to New York 36
pallets of personal protective equipment
to the state of Washington we'll be
meeting again tonight as you know the
president stood FEMA is a National
Response Center up and they are in the
lead for the the approach to the
coronavirus which is locally executed
state managed and federally supported
and will continue to surge those
resources and make sure that they're
available one last word if I may the
president reflected on the response
businesses around the country have
brought to this moment
it truly is extraordinary the president
did initiate the defense production Act
last week but as the president has
reflected many times we will use the
defense production act if we need it to
mandate production of of critical
supplies but so far no one has said no
and in fact we see industries stepping
up president mentioned Ford Motor
Company working with 3m and GE health to
expand production of medical supplies
we heard that McDonald's is now offering
curbside delivery to truckers or unable
to use the drive-thru to pick up a Big
Mac and I spoke today and president
spoke last week with Tim Cook of Apple
and Tim Apple this moment in time Apple
went to their storehouses and is
donating 9 million n95 masks to health
care facilities Apple having 9 million
mouths
and to the national stockpile there is a
level of generosity that I know is
inspiring to the president and it's
truly inspiring to all of us who are
working on the White House coronavirus
task force president's made it clear
that he hopes in weeks not months to be
able to open up the country but let me
make one last encouragement to every
American we will get to that day quicker
if every American will put into practice
the president's coronavirus guidelines
for our nation 15 days to slow the
spread if every American will do this I
have no doubt that we will slow the
spread we will protect our most
vulnerable and we will heal our land
thanks my told you that's a realistic
timeline we're looking at a timeline
we're discussing it with a very good
meeting today you know if you add it all
up that's probably nine days plus
another two and a half weeks it's a
period of time that's longer than the
original two weeks so we're going to
look at it we'll only do it if it's good
and maybe we do sections of the country
we do large sections of the country that
could be too but then we're very much in
touch with Tony and with Deborah
the perfect deadline it's a great day it
was it was based on a certain level of
weeks
from the time we started and it happened
to arrive actually we were thinking in
terms of sooner I'd love to see it come
even sooner but I just think it would be
a beautiful timeline if you look at what
we've just seen in last day or so you've
seen the number of known coronavirus
cases in the country double in just two
days
another 95 people have died just in the
last 24 hours your New York's governor
is saying this is spreading like a
bullet train across the country and the
governor of Louisiana is saying that his
country that his state I may not be able
to handle the cases that they're facing
by the by only April so what are you
seeing in all of this that leads you to
think I will reopen by mr. or even
earlier shift we're working with all of
them we can be talking about large
sections of our country because there
are sections of our country that you
didn't talk about that are doing
unbelievably well they have very little
incidents or problem very small numbers
it's very possible that they won't be
ever subject to what's happening in New
York New York is definitely a hotspot
there's no question about it
and you know what we're doing in New
York to try and help and I think we're
doing an incredible job we're gonna have
the hospitals up quickly the Medical
Center's also quickly but we'll just
have to see we have to follow it we have
to see we're gonna look at that curve
we're gonna see what it starts coming
down and we'll do the best job they can
be done Jack please push your fevers to
president doctor faster if we could just
we're looking at this idea of an Easter
timeline and I don't know that's
probably flexible what are the metrics
by which you will make the decision as
to whether you can say yes we can open
up this area of the country or no we
can't open up that area I mean well
you'd be looking at disease numbers
where you've been looking at
possible containment isolation I think
we'll be looking at a lot of things
we'll also be looking again at very
large portions of our country and I will
be guided very much by dr. Fauci and by
Deborah and by some of the other
professionals that work with both of you
and we're gonna see what what will be
but that would certainly be I think
that's a a goal that perhaps can happen
or at least for a very large portion of
our country since the president said you
and dr. Burks and others will be guiding
him and making the decision where are
you now at this time we'll have 19 days
from now so that's really very flexible
we we just had a conversation with the
president in the Oval Office talking
about you know you can look at a date
but you got to be very flexible and on
that on it literally day-by-day and
week-by-week basis you need to evaluate
the feasibility of what you're trying to
do and join you asked for you know what
kind of metrics what kind of data when
you look at the country I mean obviously
no one is gonna want to tone down things
when you see what's going on in a place
like New York City I mean I mean that's
just you know good public health
practice and common sense but the
country is a big country and there are
areas of the country and I and I refer
to this in my opening remarks that we
really need to know more about what the
penetrance is there so if we do the kind
of testing what we're doing and testing
will always be associated by
identification isolation and contact
tracing and you find after a period of
time that there are areas that are very
different from other areas of the
country you may not want to essentially
treat it as it's just one force for the
entire country
but look like flexibility in different
areas so I think people might get the
misinterpretation you're just gonna lift
everything up and even somebody's going
like that yeah I mean that's that's not
gonna happen
it's gonna be looking at the data and
what we don't have right now that we
really do need is we need to know what's
going on in those areas of the country
where there isn't an obvious outbreak is
there something underneath the surface
that says wait a minute you better be
careful and really clamp down or what
looks there that you don't really have
to be as harsh as you are and know they
so it's looking at information that up
to this point John we never had so it's
a flexible situation remember that a lot
of the country has no measures in place
to begin with far the if you call it hot
if you call it any word you want to use
it is at a level that I was speaking to
Tony before it's a level that no place
else is close it's very unfortunate you
know one of the things that this
happened that we've done I think a
really good job on I think that it's
something special what's happened is I
learned from dr. Burks a little while
ago when she said I learned it actually
this afternoon in eight days because we
kept hearing about so we did more than
South Korea time at the beginning if you
remember in eight days we're doing more
testing than they've done in eight weeks
that's a tremendous turn and with our
testing it's going exponentially it's
going up up up every day so we're gonna
be able to do things with this very
highly sophisticated testing and it's
also the test itself is considered the
best test so on top of doing now more
than anybody else we have a very high
quality test and that makes a big
difference it also makes a big
difference even in terms of opening
because we're gonna see those areas like
the hot spots but New York City
definitely is a very hot spot Steve when
you talk about areas that you could open
up what specifically are you looking at
what states are you talking about well
we're the farm belt and take a look at
the farm bill take a look at the areas
out west look at mosula spacious never
closest I was talking to the great
governor of Texas they've done a
fantastic job out there but they have
very big sections of Texas where you
know it's it's like numerous states
frankly but we can have large sections
of if we want to do it that way we could
have large sections of the country open
I think it's very important that we
start moving on that and start thinking
about it because the country wants to be
open our people want it to be open and
they wanted they want they're raring to
go and I think it's one of the reasons
that we're gonna have a tremendous
bounce-back I think it's gonna go very
quickly also I want to thank well I'm
here
I want to thank Larry for the job he's
done Steve minuchin for the job is done
if you look at Peter Navarro he's sort
of doing different things he's really
he's a force in terms of getting masks
and getting all of the ventilators and
all the things he's been fantastic Peter
but I also want to thank Congress
because whether or not we're happy that
they haven't quite gotten there yet they
have been working the long hours I'm
talking Republicans and Democrats all of
them the house the Senate I want to
thank Congress because they are really
trying to get there and I think they
will and I'll see you all tomorrow thank
you very much Wow Donald Trump not
wanting too much today
and we seem to be very quickly going in
that direction that Donald Trump has
made very clear that he wants to go in
let me make sure I get caught up on
thank-yous here
Vanessa Medina is new member number 10
today Michele Hayes is new member number
11 at join pakman.com Silvia Blofeld is
new member number 12
Brenda Romero is new member number 13 &
herrington Thank You Ann number 14 today
Rhonda Davis is number 15 at join
pakman.com and heather Gavit is number
16 I also want to say thanks to Nancy
child whose new member number 17 today
and who else am I missing here aja Hanes
is new member number 18 today david wick
berg number 19 thank you so much for
your support
Daniel Bouchard is number 20 Eileen Ward
is number 21 and I think with that I am
indeed caught back up reminder tomorrow
night 8 p.m. by the way if people are
heading out on YouTube remember to hit
like and subscribe like and like and
subscribe on the way out tomorrow night
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern is the David Pakman
show
chess tournament I am currently the
champion this is the 2019 trophy
I beat Pat that's all that's happened so
far tomorrow night anyone who wants to
play in the chess tournament 8 p.m.
Eastern I'll start streaming at about
quarter of all level well all skill
levels welcome it'll be on Lee chess org
that's li chess dot org make an account
we're all hopefully staying home for
everybody's safety everybody's health
and safety play in the David Pakman show
chess tournament tomorrow evening we'll
be back much more tomorrow clips streams
and of course the chess tournament I'll
see you then